hello everybody and welcome to a brand
new series today we are starting off our
road to one bill kind of Slash just
regular progress videos um I did a
survey last week and this actually was
the most voted idea and it's something
I've been kind of wanting to do for a
while because I've been flipping pretty
much for months now haven't really been
playing the actual game um and yeah so
what we have is a brand new account uh
we have a bond we're just going to add
on we might just pay for it with actual
money this time instead of actually
using the B bonds I'm about start with
the bond and see how it goes and um yeah
no actual goals to begin with here I
think we're going to start off with some
looting just to get some basic cash
started uh but after that we're just
going to play the game and uh try to get
as much money as we can one bill being
the ultimate goal kind of just a general
framework for the uh series um mainly
just going to be me playing the game um
so yeah let's get started so for those
who don't know looting is basically just
go to the Bounty Hunter world you're
running around picking up all the crap
on the ground um kind of looking for
sharks crom bonds Rune knives anything
else of course that's better ideal but
mostly just kind of picking up the
consumable drops doesn't require any
stats literally can just run here at
level three and just start picking up
crap off the ground and you actually get
decent amount of money from it I think
you get 2 or 300K an hour doing this
surprisingly um be able just do it for a
little bit just to get enough money and
then I think we're going to train our
magic up a little bit to start okay so
here's our first inventory of stuff
we've collected um we got about 50k plus
we still have a little bit of random
stuff to sell still um that probably
took me about 20 minutes um so I've done
better but still not too bad actually uh
so we're going to use this money to buy
some magic gear as well as some runes
just to train our magic level up a
little bit um I'm not sure what we're
going to train yet I think we're
actually do it on rats in the wilderness
that way we can get a looting bag as
well uh which is always nice to get at
the beginning of a new account okay so
here we're at the giant rats in the
wilderness I'm such a noob I'm actually
kind of kiting these rats because they
actually do a little bit of damage to me
and all I have is I think trout which is
not super great um but yeah we'll Camp
here till we get 20 magic or so or at
least 13 in the Looting bag and we hit
level two magic that's
exciting and there is level 14 magic we
can finally use the fire blast spell
which is pretty much what we're going to
be using for the next long while uh so
now we're just going to stay here until
we get the Looting bag okay so we
finally got the Looting bag you can see
we actually got 23 magic before we got
it we killed probably 100 rats uh it's
one in 30 drop rate so that's a little
bit unlucky but we got it finally um so
now with the Looting bag what are we
going to do with it I'm thinking since
we're such a low combat level maybe go
try to kill some lava dragons and loot
some white
berries it might be a little bit too low
level to actually do this but I'm going
to give a shot um because now is the
easiest time to do it I won't be getting
pked very much I think only C at level
like 20 or
something um and yeah let's see how that
goes okay so we got to run past him for
the first time here I might get one shot
still I'm not actually
sure oh this is pretty
sketchy okay I think we made it here um
so we're basically what we're going to
be doing is we're going picking up the
white berries toss them in the Looting
bag and we're going to try to oh
my going to try we're going to try to
kill one lava dragon at least um it's
going to take so long but um basically
what we're going to do attack once pick
up whiteberry toss in loting bag
eventually and yeah we'll train our
magic here for a little bit oh and there
we go we actually hit 25 magic uh so we
can teleport to verac as well okay there
is the kill let's see what we get ah not
super great I was hoping for the Visage
pretty much had all my money on
that uh but that's okay I guess we'll
take that instead and yeah we'll
probably have to hike it out of here our
Lun bag is totally full oh my God we
literally got hit for 11 and we had 12
hp oh we could eily this is awful this
is not worth it it took me so long to
kill that dragon
and yeah no okay let's go back and see
how much we actually got from this at
least okay so we ended up selling the
lava dragon drop and the white berries
prob only 30k white berries kind of
crashed over the last couple months
definitely not worth doing so I think
what we're going actually start by doing
is just tackling waterfall quests pretty
much the best quest to do at the
beginning of your account it's going to
get me a level 30 attack 30 strength
which is going to be super helpful so
I'm kind of saying [__] get this lava
dragon thing like I don't care if my
combat level goes up and yeah let's
start the waterfall Quest okay so
there's a key in here somewhere and
there's a [__] million different
boxes
okay well let's continue on where is it
okay I guess it's just the super obvious
one that's different color yeah that
kind of makes sense okay H we got the
key and let's get up here okay the next
sketchy part about this Quest is the MOs
giant which I think could probably still
one shot got me even though I have 13 HP
now um so we're going to Arro this
skeleton and hope uh we don't get one
Bang by this giant giant okay let me
just got to kind of finesse our way in
here and just grab the oh jeez we got it
for 10 okay I think we're good uh that
might have actually been the max hit so
we should be fine um so we grab the nurn
H grab another one just for safety and
yeah we'll just run out of here okay
there's the ear on the ground that is
done water Quest complete and there it
is 13,750 strength and attack experience
which brings us to level 30 strength and
level 30 attack that is pretty nice okay
so we have our really shitty gear we
manag by an adamant citar and we got
some trout and some lobsters so we're
going to go kill some chaos Druids for a
little bit okay we're at chaos Druids
here there it is three defense pretty
big milestone we've just hit there um
but actually these guys aren't too bad
at first they're going to be hit hitting
me kind of hard but as soon as we get a
couple defense levels we should be
pretty much good to go there is 20
defense finally we can wear some mythal
armor so we'll probably go gear up
pretty soon uh but for now we're going
to start training our attack okay
there's 35 attack um I think now we're
actually going to do the trome
stronghold hopefully we can get us about
five attack levels and we might get one
more first
actually okay so we got one more attack
level and um yeah we got about 100K
worth of drops which isn't too bad
pretty good for my level all the
money-making methods I know
unfortunately require money to begin
with OR require you to have actually a
skill leveled up which always helps uh
but yeah I think we're going to go start
the trome stronghold okay so here we are
at the beginning of the quest um it's
really quick Quest I think it gives you
like 15,000 attack experience which is
pretty nice and yeah we'll just quickly
complete this I believe okay we have
actually a problem here I don't think I
can kill this guy with just mythal armor
and a rune citar it's actually a bit
stronger than I thought I think we're
have to come back with a magic setup
actually okay so we're just going to
kite this guy around for the next 20
minutes or so and honestly it's going to
take forever oh a magic level actually
that's kind of nice um but yeah we'll
come back when he is dead okay uh he's a
1 HP left we should be killing him any
second now oh sorry what he's still
alive I'm confused and oh my God we
almost died um
and yeah this will be the final hit I
believe and there we go got the two orbs
and yeah we're done pretty much just go
complete the quest all right so there is
trome stronghold done uh basically just
lets you um have access to the tree of
teleportation uh this tree will just use
as mustache to teleport you around
RuneScape which is nice as well as you
get some attack experience which
hopefully will get me to level
40 okay it was actually 12,000 attack
experience that might not be enough and
damn it okay I think we're going to yeah
39 we'll have to go get one more attack
level okay so we're back at the good old
chaos Druids and there we are we just
hit 40 attack we have the Rune citar in
our inventory already so let's equip it
and yeah there we go we actually got a
half decent item okay so just to round
out our combat skills we are just going
to get to um 40 strength so you can see
they're at 38 strength so we're actually
pretty close already um we actually
noticed this ring of wealth pretty
awesome it picks up coins for you I
never even knew that um so all the coins
I must have wasted on the ground okay
there we go there's 40 strength um was
pretty quick actually we increased our
Max hit by a couple which is nice okay
so we've sold off all the herbs and we
actually managed to get our cash check
up to about 200k which is kind of okay
to begin with and yeah I think what
we're actually going to try doing is
getting our her low up a little bit
because we're hoping to
eventually um use that to make some
money by like cleaning up forars or Snap
Dragons or something like that um so
we're going to get our her blow up to
begin with and we'll see where it goes
from there okay H Quest complete we just
completed jic ritual so now we can get
our her blower level up a little bit I
think we're going to get to
25 and yeah kind of see where it goes
from there and I think we're just about
to hit 25 her BL there it is we can now
clean renar weeds uh so we're do a quick
test here to see if this is actually
going to work we only have 180k so we
cannot buy that many renars uh but
basically what we're going to be doing
is we're just going to be buying them
from the grand exchange and um
cleaning them and selling them pretty
much apparently you can get like 4 or
500k an hour mind you we do need some
starting money but we're just going to
give it a try and see how this works
okay so we cleaned all the rars and sold
them now this is just literally one
inventory pretty much and we got 7 or 8K
so I think this actually going to work
pretty well mind you we need about five
or six mil to start with so we can get
like a thousand rars and start cleaning
them uh yeah but I think this is going
to work so we'll wait until a bit later
and then we'll actually uh probably
clean some of these so I'm coming to
Edgeville and there's literally some guy
dropping the randomst stuff on the
ground I'm just running around I'm
actually getting a ton of these Adam and
kite Shields um some crazy drop parties
going on there was already a GTH in set
someone dropped on the ground uh it's
kind of random stuff like it is kind of
valuable if you pick up a good amount of
it so we're going to stay here for a
little bit and see what we can get we
even got Rune mace off the ground look
look there's Rune maces um my God
they're everywhere and um there is some
adamant plate bodies which I think were
the most valuable I got a ton of green
dragon hide bodies already uh which kind
of nice I actually getting a good amount
of money from this so far look more
adamant plate bodies literally just
everywhere trying to run ahead of the
crow it's kind of hard a little harder
than it looks like but look how many
we've still picked up already we have
like six or seven closer to eight or
nine now in the inventory just run
around look there's another
one didn't get that one NOP but yeah
still we're we're getting tons of money
from this actually I didn't even know
you could do this but look some guys
dropping the stuff on the table and I'm
trying to pick it up and I just it makes
the sound like it's picked it up but it
says too late it's gone I cannot I'm
literally clicking this entire time not
got a single one unfortunately but I
don't know what I can really do about
this okay we're back at the Grand
exchange we have just taken everything
and ran Dro parties over that was
actually a lot of fun I really enjoyed
that so this way we ended up getting 10
green Dragonite bodies eight adamant
kite Shields 11 adamant plate bodies
probably worth the most and two Rune
maces miss the GTH set which would have
been hilarious viously people would have
said rigged so I might as well have not
picked it up but anyway um this is what
we got and let's see how much we
actually got from it we 25k in the
inventory now we have 409 we got about
200k from that that is awesome um but I
think that's where we're going to end it
for today guys I hope you enjoyed
progress so far we're up to about
410k got 40 attack 40 strength 20
defense and 25 herbalore and I guess 25
magic and yeah if you guys have any
suggestions for the next episode please
leave a comment down below um it's going
to take me a lot longer to record these
so it might not come out as frequently
as my flipping videos um but still if
you liked it please toss it a like um to
see how many people are interested in
this type of series and yeah have a good
night guys I'll see you in the next
episode
[Music]